when I walked through the store I will
be just another regular 15 year old girl
if you've been binging Liv and Maddie on
Disney Plus you might be wondering what
some of your favorite stars are up to
we'll let you know who's still single
who's dating and who can't wait to get
married we'll also talk about the bad
breakup between dove Cameron and Ryan
McCartan and let you know how they've
managed to move on this is really nice
yeah there was a time when we thought
co-stars dub Cameron and Ryan McCartin
were going to go the distance together
they met on the set of Liv and Maddie
and before we knew it they were going
public with their relationship these two
were always raving about their
relationship in interviews and on social
media when they got engaged it seemed it
too good to be true and apparently it
was it's really romantic you know to
perform with the love of your life less
than a year after Ryan proposed the two
suddenly called off their relationship
Ryan made it seem as though Dov was the
one to end things while she asserted
that he had been terrible to her but now
Dov is in a new relationship and
believes this one could lead to marriage
she and Thomas Doherty met while working
on descendents two and officially
confirmed their relationship in 2017
since then Dov has called him the most
incredible person she's ever met and she
can see herself spending the rest of her
life with him in addition to acting Dov
has pursued a music career following the
conclusion of Liv and Maddie in addition
to releasing songs like out of touch and
remember me she's also collaborated with
Prive revolt on a sunglasses collection
creating new shades was a great idea
since the future couldn't look brighter
for this star while Dov didn't exactly
leave a glowing review about her
relationship with Ryan he has his own
accusations about their pasts when
talking about a difficult time in his
life via his Instagram stories ryan
revealed that his fiancee cheated on him
and left him although Dov didn't respond
to the accusation directly she did share
a quote via Twitter about toxic people
clearly Ryan and Dov didn't exactly end
on good terms but they've both moved on
okay now Ryan's in a relationship with
actress Samantha Fetty and seems to be
doing well with his career in addition
to shows like midnight Texas and
freakish he's also taken to the stage
he's been on Broadway as Hanz and frozen
Pierrot and way
kid and Jason Dean in heathers just to
name a few of his productions regardless
of what really happened between Devon
Ryan
he says he's proud about how he was able
to move on from their messy breakup it
certainly hasn't hurt his career since
in addition to acting he's also showing
off his musical talent joey Bragg played
the part of Joey Rooney on Liv and
Maddie well the bathroom floor is so
clean and that you can lick it and his
acting career also helped him beat his
girlfriend Audrey with B the two men
while he was doing a sketch for
awesomenesstv
and was dressed in his underpants and a
cape it may not have been the most
conventional start of a romance but it
worked for them and they've been
inseparable ever since
they've been together since 2013 and now
share a home not only do they live
together they work together upon SIDS
not dead
Joey claims that seeing Audrey in action
on set reminds him of how talented and
amazing she is and reminds him of why
they fell in love in the first place
it's safe to say Joey's love life is
going well and so is his professional
life since Liv and Maddie
he's been on betch packing high school
and has been cast in the ABC comedy my
village he also enjoys performing as a
stand-up comedian and spending time with
his girlfriend saying that Tenzing
Norgay trainer has grown up since his
time as Parker Rooney on Liv and Maddie
is a bit of an understatement
the show was his big break and he's been
keeping busy since it ended but show
choirs an easy a and this scientist
needs one class he can Koston Tenzing is
currently single which isn't surprising
considering that he was one of the
youngest cast members since then he's
appeared in night squad the stranded and
voice to gin in the movie abominable
he's also letting fans access his talent
via the website cameo where they can
request custom messages from Tenzing
according to Jessica Marie Garcia she
considers her Liv and Maddie co-stars
more than just friends they're her
family hey Joey
beautiful so it just made sense for the
creators of the show to be there to
officiate the wedding of Willow we mean
Jessica and her husband his name is Adam
and he popped the question in 2016 and
two years later they tie the knot yes
even though Jessica is known for playing
teenagers she's actually an adult
married woman
thanks to her time on Liv and Maddie she
says she considers herself a disney
princess
but she's found happiness in her
non-royal roles as well this star has
had no shortage of work since the show
ended she appeared in fetch how to get
away with murder Diary of a future
president and all my blog in the past
jessica admitted to feeling like the
sole brown girl in Wisconsin but now she
enjoys being part of more diverse casts
working with a mostly female crew on
Diary of a future president made her
feel freer and like she had more room to
be creative this Liv and Maddie star may
be a teenager but she's definitely a
busy one lauren lindseydawn zhis was
known for her role as Ruby but since the
show wrapped up she's had no shortage of
work she was on no-goodnik the show 101
Dalmatians and even appeared on The
Young and the Restless the star is also
getting ready to take on a major role in
NBC's Punky Brewster she'll play the
part of Punky's fashionable teenage
daughter Hannah and will work with
Soleil moon Frye from the original show
between Lauren's super busy schedule and
young age it's no surprise that she's
currently single it turns out that
holden dippledorf is living a real life
love story that started way before his
time on Liv and Maddie do you maybe want
to not awkwardly share a meal as friends
when he was 13 years old he met Ellie
woods at theater camp and the two of
them quickly became best friends they
stayed close over the years and in 2017
their platonic relationship turned
romantic for a long time his career kept
them apart but they were committed to
making their long-distance love work out
in 2019
Jordan popped the question at her
parents beach house in Birmingham
Alabama where they grew up according to
Jordan their friendship provided a solid
foundation for their relationship and he
believes he's found his soul mate he
hopes to get married in July 2020 and
looks forward to starting a family
with ally in addition to making it work
with his best friend Jordan has been
keeping busy career-wise he was an
Archibald the next big thing she around
the princess of power and to all the
boys PS I still love you while Victoria
Morales was portraying Andy on Liv and
Maddie she was also known for her role
as Hayden Romero on Teen Wolf
although she has a strong presence on
social media she tends to stay quiet
about her romantic life happy go for it
however she was kind enough to share her
quarantine song along with her partner
Jordan Wilson not only can she act but
she could play guitar too back in 2018
Jordan wished his love a happy birthday
on Instagram and thanked her for not
getting too annoyed with them apparently
they aren't annoying each other too much
during quarantine and are much more
focused on making beautiful music
together following the success of Liv
and Maddie Victoria said that she would
love to get into the world of film and
try her hand at directing but for now
fans can see her in front of the camera
on here and now down a dark Hall and
killer date you might recognize Miranda
may as lacy on Liv and Maddie but if you
don't we can't blame you Miranda has
definitely changed just cents her time
on the show and she's gotten really into
working out and staying healthy this
star isn't shy about sharing her
workouts with her fans but if she's
dating anyone she's definitely staying
quiet about it
Miranda is seemingly single but that
doesn't mean she isn't keeping herself
busy Miranda has been involved with the
show bunked as Lou Hawk Hauser and as
talked about starting her own fashion
line someday in the future if you miss
seeing Miranda on TV you can always get
a custom message from her on cameo even
before he took on the role of Artie
smalls
Jimmy Bellinger already had an extensive
acting resume but while he's happy to
chat about his career he's much more
subdued when it comes to talking about
his love life in fact it takes a careful
examination of his Instagram to see that
he's even in a relationship however he
appears to be dating photographer Liz
Fargo who wished him a happy one-year
anniversary in December 2019 more
recently he shared a picture of them
indulging in some sheet masks so it
seems like
things are going well clearly the couple
who pampers together stays together
yeah Lord leapin his hair since his time
on Liv and Maddie
he's been on shows like betcha and the
middle and is working on a comedy of
horrors Volume one even though it's been
years since he portrayed Artie smalls
he's using his Liv and Maddie Fame to
draw attention to an important cause
he's promoting an initiative by the Rays
foundation to collect masks and mouth
shields for first responders and care
packages for low-income families actress
Kali Rocha portrayed the mother of the
Rooney children on Liv and Maddie as
well as the school's vice-principal in
real life this mom has two kids of her
own and has been happily married to her
husband sound engineer Michael cracker
Qian since 2006
Callie loves acting almost as much as
she loves being a mom to her kids she's
been acting since 1993 when she took to
the stage for the play in the summer
house and made her cinematic debut in
1996 is the crucible since her time on
Liv and Maddie she's appeared on Harvey
girls forever and the show man with a
plan
although she's a talented actress she
admits that she has a passion for
comedic roles and loves to make
audiences laugh Liv and Maddie was her
first time on a show intended for
children and she was surprised by its
popularity she even had the opportunity
to pen a few of the episodes but says
that acting not writing is her true
passion in life Benjamin King played
Pete Rooney Liv and Maddie's father and
Maddie's basketball coach I shut but now
it's brand times turn this actor was
married long before Liv and Maddie was
even a thing he's been married to his
wife Laura King since way back in 2004
and even after all this time they're
still crazy about each other when he
wished his wife a happy birthday on
Instagram
he called her a dream come true and said
he's thankful for her every day not only
is Benjamin a husband but he's also a
father of two daughters he admits that
parenting as a tough job but says it's
made easier through the support of his
wife Laura clearly Benjamin has been out
of the dating game for quite some time
but he's been busy since Liv and Maddie
ended he portrayed Charles Kemp on the
show better things
Carter camp Lian the middle of X
Benjamin is also working on the movie
Shriver as Jack
what even though he's still acting
Benjamin believes that his purpose in
life is to be a good father to his two
girls which of these Liv and Maddie
stars do you hope to see more from in
the future are you hoping for a cast
reunion make sure to share your comments
with us in the comments section below
click the subscribe button and turn on
your notifications for more videos from
us here at the things thanks for
watching we'll see you again next time